It's literally all over.
Hello everybody!
Hold on.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
I'm muted right now but...
Welcome to Zort!
I'm playing today with LimeDoki, Snuffie, we're the Sluppy Sisters!
Ok, I just wanted to say hi.
I just did another stream and I did the fastest dinner and the fastest pee.
And I didn't do my time.
Anyway.
Ok, I'm gonna go, I'm gonna unmute now.
Me?
No, it's like, here, I can show you, like, how it looks.
Hold on, this is the way that it booted up for me.
Oh, it didn't actually capture properly, it just captured my full desktop and I'm gonna leak everything.
Nevermind.
Yo,
those slurs that I have saved as text files on my desktop.
It's literally just your desktop wallpaper, like, you're like, my favorite words.
My favorite words!
It's your desktop wallpaper.
All the gamer words.
Is this a scary game?
No, it's basketball.
Oh, it is?
Yeah.
There's a cat wearing a Santa hat.
When was the last time this...
That's the only reason why I picked this game.
You can play basketball in this game.
How do you even find these games?
I saw...
This is crazy.
You know, like, I always stalked a popular upcoming on Steam, and I saw this game before a while back, and I looked at the reviews.
It had 7,000 reviews, so I assume it's, like, okay.
Maybe if I do return to lobby, I don't know, it seriously won't let me invite...
It says something weird.
It says, host from here if you want to play local with your IP or offline, forward port 777 TCP and UDP for other players to join.
Your other game's progress will still be saved.
Nah, we gotta do this the Minecraft 2008 way, bro.
We gotta boot up Hamachi.
Yeah, let me boot up fuckin' Hamachi.
So, like, clearly you can play online.
Yeah, we just gotta port forward.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, dang.
I guess I have to play Ultimate Rec.
Cheap.
Oh, I figured it out.
I clicked the port.
I didn't click anything.
Wait, so you ported it.
You actually ported it?
How?
Oh, I can join you now.
Wait, what?
Mint just opening up holes in her router in real time.
Thank you, Mint.
Oh my gosh, you opened the port.
We're in her PC, guys.
We're in it.
Oh, there's local audio.
Do we want to use that instead?
We should use in-game.
Oh, we should do the pro streamer thing where we turn all of our individual vids to zero so our foogies will still light up.
Oh, you have foogies?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, of course.
You don't have foogies?
Get muted.
Okay, give me a sec.
I need to write down what I have on your Discord.
Oh, right.
I didn't actually check that, so I'm super close.
How are you guys doing a thing on Discord where your foogies still light up?
Turn our volume down to zero.
It's nothing.
Yeah, put all of us individually zero.
You're so smart.
Um, hello?
I gave the idea.
It was a collective game.
Don't worry about it, Doki.
It was collective.
I'm collectively smart.
Okay, let me see.
Oh, you can turn people individually up, too.
Yeah, I was gonna say, Kasey, you're fucking awesome.
I'm turning you down.
Okay, let's see.
Turning you guys up.
That was not a good idea.
What did you do to me?
That was a piece of pizza.
Let me pick up the boomerang.
Yeah, you can pick up the boomerang.
No, my boomerang!
Let me pick it up.
Well, let me pick it up.
Oh my god, can you suspend it?
Okay, one...
What is that?
What are you doing?
Where'd she go?
That's right.
This is exactly why I wanted to play this game.
How do you do that?
Wait, how do you...
Oh, here?
E-mail.
Oh, and then...
Let's crouch.
What's for?
Oh, okay.
Woah.
We've been in the game for 5 minutes.
That's right.
We're going full sloppy tonight.
Oh, we're getting banned.
I just wanted to twerk!
Let me twerk and step on one place and just hit you again.
Thank you so much for the sub.
Woah, my god.
It is so funny.
Wait, get in front of me.
Get in front...
My god.
Oh my god.
I was like looking through the settings and I pop out and I just see a fucking train being ran right through my screen.
That's...
Join us, Snubby!
Press ALT.
ALT and 4.
ALT 4.
What's that?
Press ALT and there's 4.
Yeah, we're just a train, guys!
Cowabunga!
What the?
Don't do it!
Did you guys see the cat up here?
Did you see the cat and his little Santa hat?
Cat?
Yeah, he's on the fridge.
There's no individual audio settings.
Why are there individual audio settings?
No, there are!
There are!
In the...
I just got master volume and voice chat output volume and that's it.
If you don't go into settings, it's just in like the pause menu, but...
No, not for people.
I want to turn down the sound effects.
Oh, the sound effects.
Did I just do it?
Alright, ok.
Also, am I loud?
Because I just noticed the thing is like my mic input volume is really high on this game.
Do I put myself like here?
Oh, that sounds good.
Or here.
Is that better?
Yeah, that's good.
Ok, less blown out.
If it's still loud, let me know because I have plenty of headroom to turn it down.
It's better this way.
Are you doing gacha?
Oh, it's normal or hard mode.
Ok, we should go to normal mode.
Wargamer!
How do you do a snowball?
Where's Snuffy?
Snuffy?
Snuffy!
Snuffy's with me.
My cat is trying to...my cat is...
I'm waiting for something.
Wait, did she crash?
Yeah, I think Intel is striking again.
Mint crashed?
No, did it go into the...wait, did it go into the game already?
No, I don't know where Mint is.
Ok, let's see.
I'm trying to turn people down.
Dang it!
I'm a little scared.
The game just randomly closed.
I'm going to let my cat out real quick.
Oh my god, you guys were in the back this entire time.
That's right.
What are you doing, huh?
I'm going to be totally looking for you at all times because you might crash and I'm going to be scared for you.
These games are scary.
I'm going to have to go through a rigorous testing process before I ever agree to another game.
Drop me behind the house.
Is this where we play basketball?
I guess so, yeah.
I think you play basketball in one of the maps.
Oh, ok.
My boss says you're crypto mining.
Can you confirm?
ENGO is basketball, guys.
That's our ENGO.
Right there.
I want a b-ball.
I want a b-ball on the court.
Yeah, I'm here for the b-ball.
Someone called me the baller.
Press to join our...
Do you think the more footprints we leave, the more likely it is that Snuffy crashes because it's taking more processing power to remember?
Whose credit card is this?
I think I dropped mine.
What?
No, this is mine.
I got it.
I have somebody's credit card.
Belong to no state, it says.
I just...
Ok, you're not getting it back then.
Get it.
How do I drop an item, actually?
I think it's ours.
It's my company employee card.
Yeah, I have two of them.
I got an employee ID.
Don't take my employee ID, chat.
Oh my god, wait.
It actually just docks my...
It shows like your code on Steam.
If you look under the snow, you might bump into...
Oh, they don't see it.
They can't see it because...
Because my Fookies are covering it.
Government ID?
This one has nothing on it.
Here, wait.
Here, take this identity.
It's mysterious.
Take that one.
Oh my god.
This game is key.
What the heck?
Whose card is this?
Wait.
It works.
There's three.
I'm creeping over to you.
Keep your legs open.
I'm sorry, what?
I feel like I'm sliding around.
Can you change my name to Zort, please?
Zort?
That looks wrong.
That looks so wrong.
I gotta get over there.
Oh my god.
Stop.
Should we try a game then?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Also, my sound volume is better now.
Bomberman.
But not really.
What's this?
Hold control of the crouch.
That's cute!
Yeah, that's cute.
Are you guys ready?
I'm gonna head to the first map.
Yeah!
I'm not the host.
Min has to select it.
Oh, okay.
First map!
Yeah?
It's all free!
Let's get them all.
We can be a symphony!
I just wanna be part of your world!
Okay!
That was so fast.
Oh my god!
Poppy playtime!
What?
There's like an actual cutscene.
Thank you for the thousand bits!
What?
It didn't mute.
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
I almost thanked him too, because he looks like he's in my chat.
So I was about to be like, thanks, man.
Thanks for the thousand bits, dude!
I thought it was muting.
Hold on, let me go find the push to mute.
Chat, I think if you give anything to Limu, it's only fair that you share.
You can't only give things to one child and not the other.
Escape the factory?
What did I just do?
Wait, I think I just did something.
I don't know.
What did I do?
Don't make...
Oh!
Thanks!
Sort of.
Quiet?
We're on TV.
That's quiet, right?
Yeah.
I hate this channel.
Oh, there we go.
Somebody in chat said we look like the Plants vs.
Zombies guy.
Oh my god, we do!
Grass.
Spice.
Tomato paste.
Metal gear.
Can you do a test with me?
Can you hear me right now?
Yeah.
What was that?
How did you get in here?
Oh my god.
How did my... How did my computer get in this game?
Is that Toa?
It kind of looks like Toa.
Hello?
Hello.
Ok, you can hear me now?
Ok, I'm gonna test.
I'm gonna mute, hopefully, and then can you hear me?
Yeah, we can hear you.
Not right now.
If you're talking right now, I can't hear you.
Yeah.
Ok, cool.
I fixed it then.
Get your flashlight.
Yeah, get your flashlight.
I got an air horn.
That's helpful, right?
Where's the flashlight?
Where did you get the air horn?
Over on the bench.
Power for ton styles.
Flashlight.
Oh, turd styles.
We are so going to get murdered by monsters instantly.
No, we'll be fine.
We'll be so fine.
How do I do it?
Oh, we have to use our ID cards here, right?
Do we?
Oh, is this just like we loot or something?
Oh, we do, actually.
No, use your ID card.
Yeah.
We are like employees here in the Zord Factory.
Don't find things to eat on the ground.
We are all going to fucking die.
What's that?
Oh, another flashlight.
What did you do?
Be quiet, this is a noise friendly environment.
Go quiet.
What is going on?
Wow!
What's happening?
I'm ill.
I saw a man.
What do you mean you saw a man?
Oh, in this.
You saw a man?
I saw a man.
I don't feel so good.
In this hole?
In the hole?
No, no.
What?
Uh-oh.
I saw the man!
I saw...
It's your fault!
He's right there!
Do you see him?
Yeah, I see him.
He's smiling at you.
Yeah, he's smiling at me.
I don't see anything.
You're not ill yet.
Maybe I shouldn't be plagued near you then.
Hold on.
Wait.
She... I think she went in the hole and got eaten.
Was that the... Wait.
It's fine.
She's dead.
I'm ill.
Don't go in that hole.
I won't.
Do you think we need to take her ID card back with us?
No, she's not...
Hey!
Hello!
What's up?
You made it back!
Where did you go?
I
think I need to go.
I don't know.
I think the man is about to get me.
Oh, there's two men!
There's two men... There's three men!
I gotta go!
I gotta get out of here.
I gotta get away from the...
Wait, there's...
There's so many men!
They're all...
They're staring at me!
Wait.
Oh no, I see the 30 twerking men, but apparently the men that they're seeing is different.
Wait, do you not hear the laughter?
No.
Oh no!
Um...
We're in the first looking room and we're gonna die.
We gotta escape somehow.
We just don't know how yet.
We can just keep exploring.
Yeah.
Oh, was it?
You made it back though.
I found a golden...
Hallucinating.
I don't know, I just hear them whispering.
They're...
They're really talking a lot.
I guess we gotta go into the other...
Oh my god.
What the hell was that?
They're getting closer!
Stop!
Leave me alone!
What have I done?
Oh, I think I might have just summoned the...
Goki?
I thought she summoned a chair.
She turned into a chair?
Then I started moving, I was like, wait, I'm alive!
What do you mean a chair?
Wait, wait, wait.
Are you real?
Are you like...
Don't talk loudly.
Loud sounds can damage you.
What are we damaging?
Wait, you're not crazy anymore?
No!
Goki, your stuff is where you fell.
If you wanna get it back.
I'm not getting it.
I'm not going back.
I don't think all the plushies are good.
I don't wanna go down this way.
There's evil men laughing at me.
They're laughing at me.
Go away!
I'm fighting my inner demons for real.
Music improves mental health.
I'm gonna improve my mental health by...
Trust me, it worked for me.
It's working, it's working.
That's how we leave.
Ok, I'm pushing it.
We haven't collected anything, so we should probably do that first.
I found one collectible.
What just hurt me?
What's happening?
I'm not moving!
I'm moving on my own!
What's going on?
Hello?
Oh, I think I gave you a concussion actually.
I'm sorry.
I just threw a bottle at your head.
Oh, I really did have a concussion.
Yeah!
I'm so sorry.
You were knocked down.
Oh,
it says waiting on the other players.
Can we not just press the button?
Our life is on the line and you're huffing gas.
No, I'm collecting things.
The gas is...alive.
What was that?
Oh, I think there's trees.
If you have a Rubik's Cube, it will make you sane, apparently.
No, I'm better now because of the music.
I'm better.
Oh, I see.
Ok, Cube restores sanity when used.
If you hit tab, you can see item information.
Oh, neat.
I hear flies.
What's the gas for?
I saw one.
I saw a gas can...crawling away.
Ok, sorry Zentraya.
Sorry.
Don't make loud.
Wait a second.
Mint Lane?
This is my home.
This is made for me.
Mint Lane.
Do we just leave now?
Maybe.
I think we can just leave because it said waiting on players when I pressed the button earlier.
What's that sound?
We're waiting.
What's that?
Oh, there's another little plashy.
Oh, I have to press the button.
Sorry.
Oh.
My bad.
Find Zordy.
Oh,
it's just repeating you guys.
Is this Zordy?
I think so too.
Let's go find Zordy.
What?
Oh yeah!
This whole area opened up.
Ok.
Zordy!
Oh look, look, look Zordy!
Zordy opens doors for you.
Reach the second floor.
Second floor goes to factory.
Oh ok.
What did I just do?
Who is this?
I just summoned him on accident.
Maybe you'll occupy his body if you die.
Yeah, I just summoned him on accident.
Nice.
Why didn't he imprint on me?
There's something coming!
It makes you happy.
What's that guy doing?
Snuffy, there's something coming!
Is that Snuffy?
He's looking at us.
Oh, he's leaving?
Oh, kind of.
Wait, is that Snuffy or is this Snuffy?
No, remember you have your guy, right?
Uh...uh...uh...uh...
Why do you have a bunch of voices going...
What is this game?
Oh my god!
Ok.
They're kidding.
They took their candy mask.
Yeah, I dropped that and they're taking it.
Ok.
What is happening?
I don't think they're supposed to take it back, right?
They're just gonna put it back on the pedestal.
They'll put it back on the pedestal, I guess.
Yeah.
Angel, thanks for the gift.
Where did they go?
Why did the bunny disappear?
Oh, what's happening?
Are they gonna summon me?
No!
Is that me?
Did the bunny thing kill Mint?
Yeah!
Yeah, it did.
Oh my god, it really is just dudes kissing.
How do I drop him?
Press G.
Put him up here.
Put him on his throne.
What's that low voice?
It's so creepy.
What are they saying?
What is that scary noise?
Yeah, drop him.
Bring me back.
I'm coming back!
I'm alive!
Oh!
Oh, thank you!
Thank you!
I have two IDs.
I don't need one.
I do need a flashlight though.
What are they saying?
No!
The bunny!
Oh, I got the flashlight.
Ah!
Oops.
What's going on?
Oh,
they are saying give me the doll.
No, we need a key I think right now, right?
What do we do with this thing?
What the hell is this?
Big king.
Give me the doll!
Oh no, no, no!
There's a guy...
Ah!
I'm ill again.
Why is everything happening to me?
Ah!
Hold on.
Hey, chill out.
No, I'm gonna use the music right here.
Thank you doll.
I know where the...I remember where there was arcade machines.
Oh wait.
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
What was that?
Oh nice, money.
That's not a real item.
Who is this?
I think I got a stalker.
Yeah, that's ok.
Yeah, throw me in the hole.
Bunny!
Oh, they grabbed it back.
Hey, how did we get in here?
How did you do that?
You guys, there's so many of us.
How did so many people...
How many people spawned?
We gotta find the high score, no?
Yeah, find the high score.
The bunny!
No!
Just keep yelling at it.
I'm good at that.
What's the high score?
What game is this?
Bonecracker.
I did it!
The door is open!
You got spectator role.
I got the door open.
Play video games.
I'm an echo!
Oh my gosh.
Gamer room.
What's this thing?
Ozmen.
Wait, what's this?
Everybody okay?
Snickers!
A bottle and bowling ball.
Weakness bowling ball bottle.
Eat some sushi.
I'll grab one.
I don't have one.
Oh, just kidding.
Grab the gas can.
So there might be a creature that's weak against it.
Oh,
you're right.
Backup generator.
What the hell?
How did you do that?
You hit me!
How do you use it?
I guess just put the gas cans by it.
Go away!
This thing is creeping...
This thing is creeping me out.
Who are you?
Yay!
Storage!
So close.
Come on, Doki.
Come on.
Creature log.
At what?
What's that sound?
Do you hear that?
Like the music?
What?
What's that sound?
Stupid!
Yeah, go away, idiot!
Yeah!
Die, stupid!
Snoopy has it right now.
I keep hearing whispers.
What's that?
Oh, you found my friends?
What the?
That guy just went under the...
Oh we gotta go activate the generator!
Get off the ground!
Come on, we got a job to do!
Let's go do the generator!
Throw the bottles at him!
Bottles are his weakness!
He's coming after me guys!
It's totally fine.
Don't worry about it.
Nice try!
You almost got him!
Where is the bottle?
Get the bottle.
Everybody get a bottle.
Wait, where do we go now?
Do we not go upstairs?
Help me!
No way!
I'm in the backrooms!
I got dragged into the...
Hello?
Yeah, I just went to the backrooms.
There is someone over here too.
Oh, watch out for the...
What's happening?
Oh, I just messed up.
Oh dang it!
Why doesn't the bowling ball work?
Yeah, she'll just end up in the backrooms.
That's just what happens.
The bowling ball.
I don't think it works guys.
Am I in the backrooms?
Oh no, I'm spectating.
I tried...
I literally...I literally clicked...You guys watch me hold the button down on that and it went all the way around.
It didn't do it.
It didn't open.
What?
You guys watch me hold that!
You guys watch me hold that button!
Oh my...I got robbed for real.
I got robbed!
You guys saw!
Bring me back!
Yay!
Ok, I held down that button earlier and it looped and the door didn't open.
I got robbed.
We could have been up here even faster.
I did!
I did.
I have the proof in the pudding.
Walked from behind.
8008?
It was in a real gas can.
Fake items.
Are you sure?
Try it again.
Does anyone have a bottle?
Is it free?
There we go.
It says don't throw it at the cheese.
So I'm gonna throw it at the cheese.
What is this?
The rat!
I think I opened the door!
I opened the door.
I just saw a spooky man.
What's the code?
I see all your friends too.
Where did they come from?
3131.
Ok!
Sure you did Doki.
Sure you did.
Trust and pits.
Wait!
Skinwalker?
Is that all those guys that are around us?
Skinwalker.
Doki died.
What?
What do you mean?
I hear her voice.
She's right here.
Ok, I'm seeing death.
I'm seeing death.
We might be boned actually.
Do you guys have an extra bottle?
We need an extra bottle.
Where are we throwing the bottles at?
I hope I don't...
The bottles we can get from the...
Ordering bottles.
Yeah, we can order bottles for free.
Yeah, they're free.
Rubik's Cube!
It's already solved.
You can't use it.
Zordy.
I'm getting a lot of...
It could be the Skinwalker.
I just read a thing about that.
Who's laughing?
Who was that?
Ok, someone get in a corner.
Everyone get in their own corner.
Who are you?
Are you somebody?
I think I need to kill some of these people.
Oh, that didn't work.
I feel like we're overdoing it.
Maybe we should try to kill some of these people.
Yeah, how do we do it though?
With the glass maybe?
With the bottle?
Wait, who's who?
Oh this is... Ok, this is the imposter.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Ok, we're good.
I'm going to die very soon.
Oh, I'm starting to see people too.
Oh gosh.
Ok, don't die.
Don't die on me.
Maybe, yeah.
Oh my god, there's more people.
There's people everywhere.
They're doing...they're e-boating.
They're twerking.
Wait, Lime.
Lime, can you go back downstairs and find a Rubik's Cube?
Yeah, maybe try to go back and see if there's a Rubik's Cube down there.
It does?
Oh, nothing's happening.
What do we do here guys?
What do you think?
Chat, is this real?
What?
What's that music?
Hello?
Oh, how did you get in there?
Wait, how did you get back there?
How did you get back there?
Doki, where are you?
Where are you guys?
Hello?
I'm trapped.
Vent from the boxes?
Where is...oh here?
Crouch.
I can't see anything.
I'm lost.
I'm just going forward.
I'm going forward.
Oh, I see some light.
Oh my gosh.
I'm going forward.
Going forward.
Guys, I can't see anything.
I don't know where I am.
Hello?
I think I'm stuck.
Where
am I?
I can't see.
I think I'm...
Yeah, I'm stuck in the vents.
I went back the wrong way.
I don't have a flashlight.
Can you guys shine your lights at the vent?
Wait, what's happening?
It just turned me around.
What?
Follow the brats.
I don't have a flashlight.
It just turned me around.
Can you guys shine your flashlights at the vent?
I'm in the fucking vent.
No you won't.
Ok, it says the person who was crying in the vent earlier.
Wait.
I made it.
I'm right here.
Let her go inside.
Oh god.
Oh no!
Stop it!
Get more bottles!
Save me!
Don't worry.
We'll fix it later.
I hate this game.
This sucks.
This sucks!
Why is it that I save somebody and nobody saves me?
I hate this game!
I'm never playing again!
Why are they ignoring you?
I don't know!
Yeah, get fucked Doki!
Yeah, I hope you get dragged to the backrooms and you cry in there.
Look at her crying.
Look at her cry.
No, I'm in the backroom!
Yeah, get stuck in the backroom Doki.
You're all by yourself Doki-Pan.
They're still coming after you in the backrooms.
It's me.
I'm here.
You're real quiet Doki.
What's going on?
What is that sound?
This is funky music.
Oh she made it!
Where is everybody?
Hello?
Oh!
Snuffy you're dead!
You're in the backrooms?
Yeah!
We're in the backrooms!
Where did our Zordy go?
Oh he's faster than you.
He's faster than you.
No.
Maybe he's not faster.
Just throw a bottle at him.
I'm trying to win!
I'm not.
No!
That's the first time I've ever seen that work!
Are we good?
Is this someone?
No.
I'm sure I will get shanked by this guy.
Good job Doki!
We're all dead!
What?
Wait no!
GG!
GG everybody!
I'm never saving your asses again ever!
I don't know who I saved but I'm never saving your asses again ever!
I tried so hard.
I was trying to move that fucking drill and Doki was just running around me like don't take me back to the backrooms.
He literally is like the same speed as you.
All you have to do is keep running.
I think we don't want to be triggering those dolls.
Those dolls just seem to summon tons of dolls at night.
I don't know why.
Ok, can we speedrun it without maxing it?
Alright.
We can speedrun that.
I'm looking at the other ones.
Oh the last one looks spooky.
Ok, let's go!
I'm too chicken.
I think we can skip this.
Just hold down space.
We can skip, yeah.
Yeah, no balls.
I skipped it.
It's hold down space.
I have to turn this on too.
Where is it?
It's Zentreya.
Thank you Zen.
God bless.
I'm ready to Zord.
This is me Zording it!
Yes.
It definitely triggered my flighter fight right earlier.
Oh yeah, that's Zording it.
Zord, Zord, Zord.
Open the Noor.
Yay!
Open the Noor!
Ok.
Alright.
I wish there was names above people.
Who am I running after?
Yeah.
What's that sound?
Come on guys!
Let's press the button!
Come back!
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, it's gonna open this area over here.
This one right here.
Ok.
Oh, me too.
There's a Rubik's Cube right here!
If you grab it, do you use it immediately?
Ok, ok.
So everyone maybe grab one.
Is this real?
I wonder.
Oh, it's real.
No!
That's a...
What do you mean it's randomized?
Do you have to tell...
Do you have to ask it?
49601?
Where do you put it in?
Oh, it's down here.
That's the door.
Is this door over here?
49601?
We got it!
There's a Zordy!
Oh wait, what's this?
What is this in here though?
Oh, antibody.
Ok.
Open the door!
I don't know what to do now.
What else is there to do?
Goodbye!
It's ok.
I distracted it.
I distracted it!
What the hell?
I just died immediately?
I just died!
Do you just have to be quiet around it and it leaves you alone?
Ok.
Good to know.
Wow, this thing is stupid.
The AI is dumb!
She's still going for it.
She's in here.
What is happening?
What the hell?
Oh no!
It's the Skidwalker!
Oh my god!
What?
They're speaking Simlish!
What the hell?
Hello?
I want to hear myself though.
Let's speedrun it guys!
Where have you been?
Get in here!
We were worried about you.
Oh they're not worried about me.
That's fine.
That's ok.
Watching all of that was so good!
Oh come on!
Donkey!
Seriously!
Wow!
I did it first try!
I think I'm dying!
I got a concussion!
No, I have a concussion!
Thank you.
I just scream at it and it kind of goes away eventually.
Wow, Donkey you are...
I know you don't be very good at throwing stuff.
I did it!
I literally did it first try the last time, alright?
I'm just saying, you know.
I had a concussion.
You can't blame me.
Oh yay!
Let's go.
I'm on.
I'm loading the data.
9898!
9898 baby!
Oh yeah!
Oh dammit there is a guy right there.
Oh now it tells you to jump.
Ok, I'm following you.
Wait...
Oh I see you.
Thank you.
Thanks!
There we go!
Wait, I can't see.
Where are you guys?
Where did you go?
Jump?
Oh there it is.
Ok.
I'm gonna push.
I'm helping.
Yeah.
Inside the bin.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's right here.
Ok, nice.
Nice, nice.
Oh, there is a skinwalker on the other side.
What's Zoron?
They honestly seem very whatever.
They don't really do a whole lot.
Does anybody have like a therapeutic kind of toy to play with?
No.
The guy is gonna start coming upstairs soon so...
Yeah, I'm gonna get more bottles so that they are just on the ground.
Be careful, be careful.
Bottles are free, remember.
Yeah, bottles are free.
Just get them on the ground.
Have them ready.
I hit him, but it's nothing.
Help!
It's over!
Was that a skinwalker next to me?
Oh no.
Wait, am I by myself?
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, where is the doll?
Oh shit.
Wait, am I by myself?
Am I eating?
Where
is the doll?
I threw it!
Why?
It's a friend in his face!
I threw it!
No!
It's ok, it's ok, it's ok.
I don't think I've ever seen anything funnier than three of us understanding the assignment and shutting the fuck up and then Doki screaming.
Screaming the entire time!
He walks up, we're all like, ok, there he is.
And Doki is just like, ok, throw a bottle at him!
It didn't work?
Why is no one helping me?
I'm screaming at the top of my lungs!
It's funny I cut the reload back into the lobby because the sound is fucked up on my end.
We'll totally get it this time.
Yeah, I believe.
I like that we have Christmas up.
Is this another game just like crab game where they kind of like got to a Christmas update and then abandoned it forever?
That just seems to happen with some of these games.
This game is new and they just decided Christmas hats would be fun.
I guess what we have to do is as we accumulate those guys we should lead them into the pits downstairs because eventually they aggro.
It was creepy because they were playing recorded audio of Snuffy going, no it's over!
Or it might have been them, I don't know.
It was really funny.
Wait, the skinwalkers?
The skinwalkers eventually started playing back the audio at me and then they turned into worms and murdered me.
Oh yeah, they will turn into worms.
You have to lead them to pits I think it said.
Yeah, once we start accumulating them we need to lead them to pits.
Oh, I have to invite Doki.
It's not letting me invite.
Yeah, into a pit.
Maybe I should remake the lobby.
I'll just try me remaking it.
I'm gonna...
Yeah, I'll remake the lobby.
Oh, unsaved progress.
Not all of our unsaved progress.
No!
Okay, I just realized I don't think I have Snuffy on Steam.
Okay, invite friends.
Alright.
I gotta add her.
No, I don't have her.
Hello?
Oh, hello.
I returned.
Who do I see jumping?
You guys saw that too, right?
There was someone like spawning.
Their footprints are right there.
There was someone like spawning in and out of existence.
Can someone invite Snuffy?
Oh there!
They were right behind you!
Hello!
Oh yeah.
It's funny.
Oh, there might be people loading in now.
Okay, are we ready?
Ready?
You guys, why does it feel like we've been playing this for 15 hours?
It's only been an hour of this stream.
We are still stuck in level 1.
We know how to...
We got this.
Let's skip.
To be fair, there's only two levels.
What was that?
I'm trying to set off the noise machine.
Okay, it's not working yet.
What?
Wait.
This is what we do.
We have to do this.
Press E on your screen and you can push the skinwalkers.
Am I pushing you?
Ah, it works!
Wait, why didn't this turn on?
Oh, I didn't hold it down.
That's why.
Hold on.
I didn't hold it down.
I just pressed it.
Oh, we don't need it then.
Nevermind.
I thought we needed it.
Just kidding.
No, we're getting atoms.
Speedrun!
Press the exit button!
I'm here.
Press H?
What does H do?
I pushed a button.
What?
What happened?
I got a Snickers bar.
Let's go.
Collecting goods.
I'm gonna get... I'm gonna get more bottles.
Oops.
My bad.
What does H do?
Why?
49601?
Okay, so it can't be the same code, but there must be a few different ones.
Nice.
Airhorn?
I found some food.
If somebody wants food...
Oh yeah, it's a bitch is just a massive bitch.
What?
What happened?
Hold on.
I'm getting all the gas cans.
Oh, nevermind.
What?
Why?
Why didn't it throw?
Oh my god.
Hello?
Why isn't it saying anything?
Why does everyone else get the cool things that sound in the backrooms, but not me?
Why?
Why not?
Oh gosh, I'm lagging so bad.
The sound bugged for me?
Wait,
what?
What just happened?
Hey, hey, hey...
Get out of...
You guys are giggling and I had to watch a minion horribly murdered by that monster.
I didn't...
How did I just die?
What just happened?
The bunny did not get me.
You just died?
I thought you died like 5 minutes ago.
I did?
She died because the rabbit came over and then the rabbit jumped at her instead of me.
Oh, there's a skinwalker in here.
I'm gonna go get rid of him.
If you guys can continue.
This one here, circling the pillar.
Is that him?
Yeah.
That's fucking right.
Yeah, you're in the wrong.
That's me.
How are we gonna get rid of him though?
I don't know if he'll follow me.
Hold on, let me see.
I don't think you can go down.
Oh, oh, oh!
It's mad!
How did you trigger it?
How did you trigger the skinwalker?
Maybe if you're alone like in the dark?
Oh, maybe it's because he took us alone.
What was the code?
He just crawled into the vent.
90, 90.
I don't know if they can crawl into the vent.
It's a little scary.
Alright, I'm ready.
He took out his full worm in front of me.
I don't like that.
Yeah, I don't like the way it looks either.
He's um, get out of here.
Get out.
I turned around and there's 30 of them.
They can't get in the vents.
Crawl into the vents.
Crawl into the vents!
They're not smart enough.
We're in the vents?
I'm in the vents.
I hid it and he seemed fine.
I don't think they can get in here.
They're not smart enough.
Yeah, I don't think they can get in here.
Find Zordy.
Who's Zordy?
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, from here on we gotta be quiet soon.
Doki bird.
Hey!
Do you think this is real?
I'm helping, I'm helping.
For real?
I'm hearing the bunny.
Do you think the music is real?
The bunny is the music, yeah.
The guy is gonna...
Oh, come
on.
I hate my life.
Off to the back rooms you go.
Have
fun.
No!
Doki!
Come on, live!
Not the bitch, not the bitch, not the bitch, not the bitch, not the bitch, not the bitch, not the bitch.
Oh, she's juking him.
That is very unfortunate.
Go, live, go!
Run, run, run!
That's a skinwalker, that's a skinwalker, that's a...
You!
She could've looped him forever and had it so that they could never advance.
It would've been great.
Welcome to the back rooms.
She made it to the back rooms!
I glitched or I started lagging so badly in here, so bad.
She was holding out for me.
That's not real.
Real.
Maybe I'll win the level by doing nothing.
Hey, what's up?
Is this one not real?
No, no, no, we're all real, we're all real.
No, kill Doki!
Kill Doki.
Luigi strats.
I'm getting carried, baby.
I'm the princess.
I'm the princess, I'm the passenger princess.
Yeah, do it.
Oh, she's trying to atone for her sins.
I'm sorry.
I'm atoning for my sins.
Shut the fuck up.
Come here, go into the pit.
Go into the pit.
You know what you've done!
Come on, let's go help.
Maybe.
Do
you have an air horn?
Do it.
Oh, he's not after us.
Man's behind me.
What?
Saw a man.
Don't look at it, I think.
We're after them.
That's not...
Who is that?
I don't know.
I don't know who that is.
Is everybody dead?
No.
I think so.
I don't think so.
I think everybody's dead.
The guy is all the way over there.
No way.
Wait, everybody's dead.
We should stay together.
Wait, where are you?
They're multiplying, they're multiplying.
Is everybody dead?
Oh no.
Oh, I'm real, but some of these aren't real.
Okay.
Okay, the ones crouching by you aren't real.
We should push them.
Push.
Oh, big guy's coming.
You guys!
Seriously,
leave me alone.
I'm with you.
Okay, there's an imposter behind you, because Doki's freaking out.
Yeah.
Yeah, he's next to me.
I see him.
You could help, you know.
You could help, imposter, if you want, you know.
I'm helping.
No, I mean the imposter.
Saying he could help.
Doki's being great, babe.
I know.
That's me.
You pushed me.
We're almost there, Doki!
We're almost there!
Is Snuffy back?
I heard...
Snuffy's been here.
She was shoving that clone.
Oh!
Oh, I didn't hear you!
Hey!
What do I do?
Push button for exit.
Okay, running, running, running.
Can we go in?
Oh, I didn't realize you could go around it.
Escape the factory!
Get me in the car.
Repair the car!
Wait, we gotta repair the car!
Get the car!
Build the car!
Oh my god, build the car!
Where's the parts?
I don't see tires.
I found a tire, but it disappeared after I dropped it.
What is happening?
Tire, tire!
Tire, did it bug out?
Did it bug?
I don't know.
Oh no, I just got back.
I had a tire, but I dropped it.
I found one, I found one!
Oh nice, nice, nice.
What's going on?
Okay, need a gas can.
Gas can, gas can.
I have a gas can, I have a gas can, where do I put it?
It's here, here, here, here.
Where I am, this side.
Left side, left side.
Left side!
Can we go?
Oh, button, button, button,
button!
How do I get in?
Did
we get in?
I think we did it, I think we did it!
What's happening?
I think we did it.
How many tires does a car need, guys?
I clutched that Zord around.
I had Zord chasing me the entire time while you pushed that drill.
Dude, I just heard you like, moaning and him groaning.
And I could not even imagine how you were juking him for like, questions.
I saw binary numbers, he was putting numbers on my screen.
How?
Yeah, we did it!
We're so good.
Wow.
I got escaped from Zord again.
That was the best bait ever.
We did it, guys.
We don't want to think so, but I think that was the most engaging coordination.
We locked in.
It only took us three tries, guys.
It only took us three tries, but we did it, guys.
Just want to play basketball.
Is this the basketball level now?
Maybe.
Oh, sorry.
I just clicked it, sorry.
Roadtrip!
It feels like we're flying.
Press H.
I'm grateful you saved me from that factory.
A pretty lady.
Veneta.
You're my life.
You're my sexy car.
Hey, Veneta.
She's meeting us in the sexy woods.
Alright, let's go.
You're in the woods?
Wait, she has a voice for you guys?
She's just squeaking for me?
Oh yeah, she's squeaking for me too.
I'm the one in the van.
She's got those kind of squeaks that you only understand if you know a woman's touch.
Exactly.
Oh, we're so desperate, but we're sad.
There's a car behind us.
I think there's like an evil ex-car boyfriend chasing us, you guys.
Oh my God, Herbie, is that you?
Wait, is the villain the car?
Because that would be Peach.
I don't think he likes that we're pushing this car out in the woods right now.
I think he's jealous.
This is...
Oh, watch out!
I ran out of the way.
Why did I die?
I literally ran out of the way.
He literally ran... I ran out of the way.
I think I got desynced probably.
Oh, I think you... I think it's like you don't stop running basically.
I think you just gotta keep running.
Keep going!
Oh, where did Snuffy go?
Uh-oh.
Okay, he's so far.
Look at him.
I'm not looking back.
Bro, what you gonna do?
Where do I go?
They touched the stone!
Oh, it crashed for Snuffy.
It crashed.
We'll try and get her back in.
Am I dead?
Hello?
Are you dead?
Everybody's dead.
What happened?
Hello?
I think Snuffy crashed.
Yeah, Snuffy crashed.
I don't know.
I touched the stone and it was like waiting for players and then nothing happened.
I ran out of the way of the car and then it ran me over somehow.
I don't...
It's like teleported to me.
I saw a hole and then I...
I think we should keep going.
Yeah, I think so.
I jumped into the hole and I died.
Yeah, because holes have had such a great reputation in this game already.
It was glowing though.
It was different.
Let me reinvite Snuffy.
Yeah, thank you.
It was different.
It won't let me click it either.
The hole was glowing, guys.
It was so different.
Oh, I can only invite her to watch VBridger.
Oh my God, no.
Should I remake the lobby?
Let me see if it's like...
Can you do it, Doki?
Because it's registering me as only playing VBridger.
I'll remake it.
It says no lobbies for her.
It's okay.
Okay, we'll remake that.
And also she's like up here.
I think she's invisible, right?
The game is a little scuffed, you guys.
The game is a little scuffed.
Yeah, I might have bugged when she DC'd.
Another perfect game.
At least we're all playing together, right?
We're all playing together.
As a sister family.
We're a pack of sisters.
Invite me again.
Okay.
Except when you're DCing.
Let's see if anybody spawns here before they come in.
We'll know when someone joins the lobby.
They glitch in over there.
She always wanted a sister.
I always wanted a brother.
Is anybody here?
Another invite?
Why?
I did.
Doki is messaging me.
She's like send me another invite.
Let me do live.
I can only watch?
Oh no.
Okay, we'll leave.
Return to menu.
Host game.
Okay,
let's try again.
Invite Doki.
Invite Limu.
I gotta add Snuffy.
Did I see something?
I always wanted a brother.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wrong one.
I always wanted a brother.
I always wanted a brother just like you.
Nobody is joining my game.
I am inviting.
Okay, I'll reboot.
Oh, it's showing VTube Studio for me.
Okay.
Quit.
We gotta quit the game, everybody.
I always wanted a Beretta.
Alright, um... Zort.
Oh, yes.
Wait, I already installed this feature.
Skip.
Yay, launder software.
Please.
Okay.
Host game.
Yeah, we're getting Zort.
Yeah, we're getting it all Zorted out.
Okay, invite.
I'm here.
Watch this.
Hi!
You made it.
We did.
Beautiful.
We need Snuffy to get in here.
Yeah, let's surround where Snuffy will be with the...
With this.
Have you found that the directional audio is sometimes really weird?
Like, sometimes it's like...
Someone's really close and it'll be like, no, you can't hear them.
Yeah, I think there's like a...
In the backrooms, it like fucks up your audio.
And everybody sounds like you're in like a hole somewhere.
When I watched someone... I think it was Snuffy went to the backrooms.
What?
Oh, wait, Snuffy's here.
Praise be to Snuffy.
Let's do it.
We got this.
Alright, let's go.
Touch the rock or we die.
Or is it Dwayne?
Don't go into any holes, guys.
Did we touch Dwayne or Johnson?
The rock?
Should we skip this?
Oh, no, I think Snuffy crashed again.
Her chat's freaking out.
No!
I wonder if we can just like, re-invite her.
Yeah, I wonder if it's the car level.
Yeah, can we re-invite her after this section, maybe?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, maybe we'll see.
I'm following you.
A little bit more intensive.
Are you still alive?
I'm alive!
I'm right here!
I'm here.
The music kinda goes in.
I'm following you guys since you know which way to go.
It does.
The car is
also going.
Touch the rock!
Touching rock!
We touched rock!
Escape before the fence is broken!
I'm coming!
We did it!
Let's see if we can invite her.
Let's... Should we try re-invite Snuffy?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It won't let me, so...
Let's try re-invite Snuffy.
No!
Wait, it says invite friends again.
Oh no!
I don't think she can do car level.
Unless like...
Unless she can try to grab this even harder, even further back.
She said potato.
There's no going back.
There's no going further than potato.
No going...
No!
There's a basketball hoop!
What?
We just found a basketball hoop!
No!
We're pouring one out for you, Snuffy.
Should we try one more time?
That part's not very long, but...
I didn't mean to do that, sorry.
Oh, it's a shop!
What's this?
Who's that in there?
There's a Pikmin in there.
What just happened?
I don't know.
He just... He exploded!
OK, guys.
We have to go back to the main menu and invite Snuffy back.
I have to play ball.
We do.
It's important.
I gotta be ball.
OK.
Alright, Snuffy.
We're going back to the main menu.
Return to lobby.
We need a ball.
Alright, invite Snuffy.
You must not pause for real.
Yeah, you can't pause in a multiplayer.
Yeah.
We might have to restart the lobby.
It's so finicky.
OK.
I'll remake it.
I can't invite her again.
Well, at least the car part isn't very difficult.
Host game.
I'll just... I didn't... I didn't even think of which way we were going.
So, I don't know it at all.
So, I'm just gonna follow them.
I'm just gonna follow them.
We got this.
It'll work.
We will play be ball.
We will be ball.
Wait a minute.
What are you doing to me?
Wait, lay down in front.
Oh wait, on the bed?
Oh my god.
No, ma'am.
Back up a couple of spots.
There we go.
Join us.
What was that?
Learn.
You know what to do.
There's a fart button by the way.
Hi, Snuffy.
Hi,
Snuffy.
Is this what happens when you get fed the Zort beans?
It gives you the massive Zort gas?
It's H.
Go stand up beside the bed.
In the corner.
Snuffy just likes to watch.
She's got the chair in the hotel.
Do you think that this will throw off the skinwalkers?
Oh yeah.
Yes, skinwalkers don't got, we got.
Alright, I'm gonna go start the game.
I'm gonna go.
We're gonna do this.
We got this.
We got the car, Snuffy.
Surely it won't shatter into a million Lego pieces upon loading in.
Snuffy, if we don't see you after this...
Yeah, take us out with you.
OK, I'm skipping.
Wait, should we...
OK, maybe we don't skip it.
Wait, should we skip it?
I don't know.
I'm scared.
OK, I'll skip.
I'm gonna skip.
OK, run!
Snuffy, are you here?
Just run!
Run!
Yeah!
You're here!
Yeah, touch the stone and then we're gonna run again.
Yeah.
Oh god.
I'm OK.
I'm touching.
There we go.
We made it!
I almost didn't make it.
I think there's a mine over here, guys, so watch out for the mine.
Yeah, B-Ball.
Oh my god, not the...
That's right.
She's gone!
She was so young!
No!
I miss her.
I like how you make squeaky noises on the field.
Yeah, I think it's really funny.
What's that sound?
Probably nothing good.
Yeah, I don't think that was good.
Oh, I think that resets the score.
Is that storm getting closer?
Is it the storm that is approaching?
I played basketball!
That's right!
What does the button do?
And what do you think this does?
2 for 2!
That's a half court, but OK.
Did you just hear a scream of agony?
No.
No, I'm playing B-Ball.
OK.
Oh,
where is she going?
To get the ball.
OK, watch this.
This is going to be the shot of the century.
What was that sound?
Are you talking about that storm over there?
Over there?
Why does he keep doing that?
I don't know.
What's that sound?
Should we explore?
I don't know.
I feel bad for Snuffy.
I feel awful for Snuffy.
We need to collectively...
You know, the next Sloppy Sister stream should be us commentating as she tries to fucking build a computer in real time.
Yeah!
Zort Ball!
Passing it to you?
Passing it to me?
How are you faster than me?
Aww, so close.
Oh, look at that!
Whoa!
Oh shit!
Oh god, I fucked that up.
So bad.
Wait, she's listening to me?
Snuffy, look what's there!
Wait, what's his name?
What was the point of that?
We don't even know.
No, there was no point.
Snuffy!
Guys, it's such a beautiful night for Snuffy.
Can you hear me?
Snuffy!
Oh golly!
We'll miss you, Snuffy.
Let's go back to the lobby.
We can't do this without him.
People are saying you can B-Ball in the lobby, but I think you have to beat episode 2 to unlock the basketball court.
Right, that makes sense.
Alright, Snuffy, the moment your PC is fixed, we're all coming back here for basketball.
I just heard that scream.
I'm gonna blow myself up with the mine!
I'm gonna watch, do it!
Do it, don't be a pussy!
Wait, let me blow up with you.
I'm gonna blow up with you.
Wait, before you do it, you should grab a basketball.
Oh, sorry!
Oh, is it the kind where you have to move off?
Once you're on it, you're...
Oh gosh, I'm in the back room.
Do these hurt?
No, they just run up to you.
My thing is bugged though.
And I'm bugged!
I wish I could hear them speaking backwards, it's so fun.
The back room always makes me lag.
I've become 2 FPS.
I went to the back room.
Yeah, it's kind of awkward.
Oh, here he comes, I think.
Wait, let's not...
Don't touch it and see what happens when it gets close to us.
What if he's actually a horrible betrayer?
There's a skinwalker.
It could be Snuffy.
Zombie Snuffy.
Snuffy, we're gonna... I'm gonna take you to the back.
Come on, get over here.
Get over here.
Get out of here.
Get out.
Oh, it likes me now.
There's a mine on the other side of the basketball court.
Oh yeah.
It's over this way.
Come follow me.
Why does the mimic have a flashlight and I don't?
I think it took my flashlight.
Wait, is this a trampoline?
No way.
Are you real?
Yeah, I'm real.
The big one is over there by the court.
Alright, don't worry.
Wait, he died.
I'm gaming?
Guys?
I think I did an impossible feat.
There's two of them now.
Hello?
I'm real.
Where did Doki go?
I don't know.
Oh, she found something.
Oh, she's collecting things.
Snuffy said she could try without VTube Studio.
Oh yeah, if we wanna try it.
Yeah, I'd be down for it.
If she turns off everything except the stream surely...
Or sorry, except the game.
Surely everything would work out fine.
Surely.
OK.
Alright, I'm gonna... I'll go... I'll make... Return to the menu then.
Alright guys.
Surely.
Don't call her Shirley.
She's Snuffy.
Snuffy!
Sorry guys that we're always having so many issues.
At least we were able to complete the first level.
If anything, you know.
I wonder.
I found a guitar!
I was gonna jam and then the lobby disappeared.
We're trying for... This is for Snuffy!
Snuffy!
This is for Snuffy.
I don't know.
Hopefully she saw my message because...
I was like a couple minutes late on responding to her.
Oh!
I wonder if she should...
I wonder if she should close Discord.
So I was playing Henry Stickmin the other day and...
There was like a weird glitch where it...
Where it like...
Kept breaking the game if I had Discord open.
That's weird.
Leave me alone.
Oh wait, you caught it.
Wait, I can catch it.
Oh I can!
Alright, 2v2 basketball.
See you in the courts.
Wait, turn around?
I think she left.
I don't know.
She's not responding on Discord.
She said she could try one more time and I was like 3 minutes late to seeing that message.
So she might have just given up and...
Disassociating somewhere.
Let me see if she's still there.
She's chatting on stream.
I'm gonna go harass her then.
Hold on.
One more try, Snuffy!
One last run, Snuffy!
One last run!
She locked up the basketball court.
Okay, she's off.
She's off.
She saw my message so she's coming.
Oh!
Okay, okay.
I went and creeped on her stream.
I heard her.
This is it.
I got a good feeling.
Yeah, let's make the shrine.
Yeah, right here.
She's gonna spawn right here.
Okay.
It's gonna be really awkward if she takes a while to get here.
No, I believe.
Trust, trust.
I believe.
I believe in her.
Yeah.
Snuffy, we're all here for you.
Everyone, send Snuffy your energy!
Yes, Snuffy!
Praise be, Snuffy!
Praise be!
We're here to zort!
That's what they call it nowadays.
Praise be, Snuffy!
Oh, mighty Snuffy!
Wait, did you send an invite to her?
I sent her a couple, yeah.
Have any good zorts lately?
Oh, dude, if you turn the camera down, there's a really weird crotch seam on the model.
I don't see it.
No?
I can't see it.
It's like a melded seam.
Weird.
I don't see it.
It's too dark.
I see my ass.
I see my ass, too.
You see his ass?
Perfect.
Oh, I do!
Oh, wow!
You see his ass?
It's like ribbed.
Whoa!
That's what I mean!
Oh!
I was not expecting...
I was not expecting the zort to be...
to be packing up there.
Or down there.
You think?
Yeah.
No wonder he does this.
Hey, hey, hey.
Snuffy could be coming in any second.
Get back into position.
Hey!
I have come back.
Welcome back.
We were so close to people.
I know.
Okay, I'm completely naked now.
This is my last resort.
Okay.
You're gonna be zorting in the nude?
Alright, let's do it.
Let's do it.
Let's zort in the nude.
Zorting in the nude.
That's how our parents did it, baby.
Is she here?
Alright, we're skipping.
Okay.
Run!
We're running, we're running, we're running, we're running.
We're running, we're running, we're running.
Snuffy's just gonna have to make noise constantly so we know.
Oh yeah, she's zorting.
Zort, zort!
It's okay.
Trust, trust, trust.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Still good.
We just lost somebody.
It's fine, she probably went to the back rooms.
She probably went to the back rooms.
Yeah, it was an intentional fall.
We're touching.
Okay.
Run, run, run.
Running, running, running.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna live through this.
Okay.
To the B-Ball!
To the B-Ball court!
Okay,
we're here.
Don't touch the mine.
Oh my god!
Run!
B-Ball!
Oh, there's a... oh gosh, there's a man behind me.
I'm not looking at him.
I'll do that too.
B-Ball, B-Ball, B-Ball!
Alright, team cheesy!
Let's get in the teams everybody!
Alright.
Skins and shirts.
How are we gonna tell who's who?
I got one for a Snuffy.
Oh no, there's no PDC.
This is for you Snuf...
Oh, she dropped her ID card!
She's gone!
Snuffy!
Accidentally twerked on our corpse.
Even the little ball is mourning.
Yeah, I know little guy.
We will...
Guys, go find me for Snuffy's PC so we can B-Ball.
Alright.
She would want this guys, guys.
She would want this.
What, the twerk?
She wants us to twerk on her?
Okay.
Yes, she would want this.
Meet me!
What are they doing?
I'm expecting these things to explode or something.
I know, right?
We could just twerk until we die.
We're like...
We're basically Kesha.
We're just partying until we die.
We're just like...
What was that?
That's a party over there.
Hell yeah.
At least they're also sad for her too.
I hope she knows that we're twerking for her in memoriam.
In memoriam.
We're like merging into each other as we twerk.
Yeah, it's good though.
2025 to 2025.
They're so needy, these things.
We're going out in...
We're going out in style.
Let's all stand in the mines and die for her and then we'll call it there.
Okay.
Whoever goes to the back rooms just, you know...
That's a bad noise.
Do you want to get away from here, little meeps?
3, 2, 1...
We gotta get off of it, remember?
Off.
Who died?
What is that?
Hello?
Hey.
Were you in the back rooms?
No, I didn't die.
What?
What are you doing?
I lived!
Here's another one.
Alright.
You leave and then maybe I'll trigger it.
You gotta count.
I thought we were gonna leave at the same...
Okay.
These things kill you?
Are they just spooky in here?
They really do act so realistic, don't they?
I'm 5 FPS.
I'm guessing Lime died and left.
Am I gonna be the only one here?
I want to explore, but I will hold...I will refrain until we can all play together.
I will refrain.
Return to lobby!
It was fun!
Yeah!
We'll find...one day find a game.
We'll do chapter...we'll do the second one when Snuffy fixes her computer.
Yeah, yeah.
We have many games we must revisit.
Wait, there's a cat up here.
I never saw this cat.
Yeah, I saw a cat in the beginning.
He's very cute.
Yeah, I didn't see him.
He looks like Snuffy.
Or Snuffy.
Goodbye, Snuffy!
Thank you, everyone!
Thank you!
Bye-bye!
Bye!
Yay!
Sorry for the shorter stream, guys!
Sorry that also we had so many issues with it.
But I hope you guys enjoyed the game!
It was very silly.
It was fun.
I will be in Japan for the next week and a half.
I'll be back on the 10th which is...
Mint day.
Minto no hi.
The 3 is mi.
Mint.
Min.
And then the 10 is to.
So I'll be back for Minto day!
And...yeah.
No, it's not Mario day.
It's Minto day.
Have a nice trip in Japan!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you!
I...I don't know.
Maybe I'll miss you or something.
What am I...
Who am I kidding?
I can't wait to...
I'm ready to get out the door.
Here I go.
Here I leave on my trip.
OK.
See you guys when I get back.
But I won't miss you.
You'll miss me.
OK.
No.
Don't just cry the whole time.
Don't make a mess.
You know, wash the dishes and...
Don't answer the door to strangers.
Stop crying.
I know you guys will miss me so much.
I won't miss you guys at all.
Yeah.
You know...
And, you know, don't keep counting down the days or anything till I'm back.
Don't be thinking.
Don't, you know, party, party, party.
I better come back and this maid cafe better be just as abandoned as I left it.
With cobwebs and with...
dust all over the place.
OK.
Here I go.
Alright.
Cafe is closed now.
See you later.
OK.
That was me closing the door.
Why did that...Why did that...
10 second sound effect...
Literally the video was 10 seconds.
Why did it have a damn intro?
Oh here we go.
Wait.
This is a better one.
OK.
I'm closing the door.
Bye bye.
Don't miss.
Don't cry.
Alright.
Here I go.
OK.
I'm always haunting you.
You thought you could get rid of me?
Bye-bye.
See you when I get back.